hello everyone and welcome to today's
live panel discussion questions about
quality control
i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i'm
going to be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational panel discussion is
sponsored by
bio rad laboratories i'd like to invite
everyone to participate today by
submitting
your questions during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send any questions we do not
have time for
during the presentation will be captured
and responded
to through the q a that will be posted
later in the event
resources box if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
please also submit your concerns in the
ask a question box and we will address
your
issues as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner
of your presentation window and follow
the process to obtain
those credits now let's get started
today's
qc panel discussion will be addressing
your questions about
quality control we have received many
questions
and we'll start with the most recurring
questions during this session
also always add additional questions and
if time allows we will address
these questions during the webinar today
we've invited
four lab directors to provide you with
their insights that are based on their
experiences with
qc practice applied in their labs
joining us our first panel member and
panel moderator
will be dr david grenache president of
the american association
for clinical chemistry he is a chief
scientific officer for tri-core
reference
laboratories in albuquerque new mexico
he's also
in the medical director of the chemistry
immunology
and esoteric analytic chemistry labs a
clinical professor of pathology
at the university of new mexico he's a
diplomat
of the american board of clinical
chemistry and a fellow at the aacc
academy his research interests are
centered on leveraging
longitudinal laboratory data to gain
insights
into population health and the
diagnostic tests
used to manage the pregnant patient
our second panel joining us today will
be dr nicola
balman she is a co-director of the
clinical
laboratory and director of central
processing
at the mayo clinic in rochester dr
billman was a faculty chair
for the aacc certificate program on the
patient safety
essentials of laboratory professionals
and she has served
as a cls document development committee
on statistical quality control
c24 she is currently the program
director of the mayo clinic
chemistry fellowship program and her
specific area of interest
include improving quality in the
automated
clinical laboratory our third panel
member joining us today will be dr mark
savinsky he is the director of clinical
chemistry and point of care
at the dartmouth hitchcock medical
center in lebanon new hampshire
an associate professor of the pathology
and laboratory medicine
at the guy school school of medicine in
darmouth
in hanover new hampshire dr zavinsky is
actively involved in the education
of pathology residents and has served in
the departmental
clinical competency committee for the
last four years
and recently he completed his first year
as the chair of this committee
additionally dr savinsky developed
dhmc's
moving average program to detect shifts
in
assay performance between scheduled
quality control
events finally our fourth panel member
dr jolie strasiski she is an associate
professor of pathology
at the university of utah school of
medicine and is a section
chief of clinical chemistry and medical
director of
endocrinology and automated core
laboratories
at arup laboratories a national
reference laboratory in salt lake city
utah
she's an active member and holds
leadership positions with the american
association for clinical chemistry
and the american society for clinical
pathology
for a complete biography of all of our
panel members please visit the
pyrography tab
at the top of your screen welcome to all
four of you
dr grenache you may now begin the
presentation
panel session great thank you susie very
much and uh thank you all for attending
the
this morning or i guess yeah this
morning
um so as susie mentioned we had some
questions submitted in advance
and uh we're gonna go and we put them
into buckets so we'll try to
uh uh sort of themes going on uh but
uh if you have questions please do
submit them
via the q a box and we will try to weave
them into our discussion
as we go forward so um the first
sort of theme uh questions regarding in
a theme were
about the best way or the best
procedures
to set qc ranges so we're going to take
some questions in that space first
and i'm going to ask dr straszewski to
kick us
off um by answering this first question
which basically says what what's a lab
to do
if you aren't able to generate enough
qc data from a new from say a new lot of
qc material
before you have to put it into
production what what strategies do you
use at air up
so it's obviously this happens
this is something that i'm sure
everybody on the panel can can speak to
as well
um but again this is kind of referring
to when you're using
similar qc material or the exact same qc
material
it's just a new lot so hopefully
everything else is relatively similar
but again you just didn't have enough
time to to run enough data points
so i think a pretty common practice is
to take the previous
either the previous cv or the previous
standard deviation
from really as long of a period of
historical operations that
that you can because you want to get a
good representation
over time and then run that new material
a few times so an n of 10 is often
referred to and that is actually what's
recommended with the
clsi document that was referred to
earlier the c24 guidance
and that is a good resource for folks as
well so an end of 10 is mentioned there
and so that's going to give you your
short term mean that can be used um
and it really ends up just and it ends
up being really just a bridge
right so it's a bridge to the new lot
and then of course you're going to want
to update
those those data points once you get
more data points you can update that
mean
i would point out and i'm sure others
will agree that you really need to watch
this carefully
right because you i almost assume going
into it
that the range is inadequate right
because we have a smaller number
of data points than we normally would
like to so
um i would say you in the real world you
want to make sure that you're
watching that very carefully and then
get enough data points to move forward
i would also say that that's if the
concentration is similar to what
you were originally running if you had a
different material or a different
concentration you
you could use the cv from whatever
current material that you're using
that's
that's closest again if you're if you've
got um
very similar cvs across the range then i
think that this
can work um if you've got wildly
different performance
at the low end versus the high end or
something like that i would not
recommend doing this
but um but you could use that to
estimate the standard deviation
then at the new concentration so well
thanks and i i saw a doctor's bauman and
sirvinsky nodding their heads a lot uh
so
do either of you have anything to add
thank you go ahead yeah i
completely agree with dr stacevsky and
and i will say you know just for
practical purposes our quality
specialists in the lab
actually set alerts on their calendars
for two weeks after establishing
to re-review that mean so so that we
make sure that we're really doing it
um again just helpful little hints um
it's kind of captain obvious but it
works for us
oh that's a good idea i we have uh we
try not to have this happen but
as jolie alluded to it it eventually
will happen to everyone
um the challenge i find is when you do
set your ranges and three days later you
see a shift
and you have to ask yourself is this a
real shift or not
um and when that happens if we're lucky
enough to have some well characterized
material
that we use for like lot a lot
verification or previous proficiency
testing material
we can rerun that to make sure that
we're not seeing an assay shift
and this is just a shift in um really
we're taking a small little snapshot
we're trying to apply it so we've used
that to um
verify that we're not having an
analytical deviation
yeah i i i would agree with all of that
um i like
uh dr bauman's idea of setting a
reminder often
we don't do that and oftentimes um our
reminder is
when we have frequent qc failures and we
look at the lj
chart and like well i see a shift
what happened back here and then it's
like oh well we set our new mean but um
you know
maybe without enough data and so and
that's really where sometimes the value
of having access to peer data helps us
too
making decisions about uh if we're going
to make an adjustment or not
all right thank you um so here's an
here's another question
um if if if the control material
is from the same manufacturer of the
reagent
that you're using for a test uh is it
acceptable to use the
the qc means the means and the sd ranges
that come
uh in the package insert material uh or
should a laboratory
calculate their own mean and um uh
and use the company's sd so what's in
other words what's the best
practice should we um should we be using
what is provided to us in a package
insert
or should we be establishing our own
metrics um
so dr savinsky why don't you take that
one yeah so
for the most part we establish our own
means
and standard deviations when we do have
specified means and standard deviations
and part of that really is
that if you look at some of the
manufacturers qc
ranges they're quite wide and that's
because they're they're really trying to
apply
that material to a huge number of
analyzers
across the globe across the country and
consequently you're going to see some
differences between calibrations
and so the sbs get quite wide i will say
that
for some analytes that tend to be more
harmonized
the mean is actually quite valuable so
that
you can see if globally when you're
setting up a new assay or a new material
you can see if your essay is performing
in the ballpark of what you would expect
i do think it is important that if you
are going to use the means and
standard deviations of the material i'm
sorry rather make your own means and
standard deviations
and the manufacturer provides them i
think it's a good idea to also
look at what the manufacturer thinks
those values should be
so that you're not setting your mean
outside of what their expected ranges
are
that would to me signal a very large
problem so for instance if the range is
10 to 20 and your mean is at 30 that
could be a problem that you might want
to investigate
that's a fairly big difference in
performance
thank you any of the other panelists
i would just say don't do it
don't use the manufacturer's main nsd
ever so i have a stronger opinion on
that
um i think the whole power of
statistical qc
is that you're using the mean and sd
that you've established on your analyzer
in your lab yeah
yeah i i think it can be a guide which
is exactly what dr cervinski is saying
but it's definitely not a replacement
um so i i i also don't support it as
best practice but i also know that
it happens and again sometimes people
just want to look back to that and again
use it as a guide but
yeah you know and a a related question
has come in
in the q a box and it says you know how
often should you should you update your
means
and so um i guess i'll start with dr
bauman
what's best practice like when when
should you update your me
so don't touch those means um
as infrequently as possible would be
my advice if you get into the habit
of adjusting a mean every time you see a
slight shift or a slight trend
you have to remember that that mean that
you established
is your benchmark for stability over
time and that's why we're doing qc
so you don't want to tweak that mean to
make it easier on yourself that mean
needs to stay
stay what you set it for as long as
possible
now i can say in in my laboratory we
actually have
a process that we go through if a mean
needs to be adjusted
because perio periodically they do maybe
there's a new lot of reagent
and there's actually a qc matrix effect
we would then use patient comparison
data
to help ease our minds that that
adjustment is okay
there's degradation of qc material that
happens you need to adjust to account
for that
so there are definitely reasons to
adjust a mean
but i think it really has to be a
systematic thought process
that you're asking yourself all of the
questions
that make you comfortable that you're
adjusting a mean appropriately
and not to advertise
c24 too much but there is an appendix
in c24 that we put together about the
questions to ask yourself
when you see a mean that may need
adjustment and it kind of walks you
through all of those steps so did a
reagent lot change
is the qcn nearing its expiration date
how do you compare to your peer group
have you done patient comparisons to see
if there actually
is true bias or a true shift
so i think the short answer is adjust
those means as
infrequently as possible and when you
need to adjust them
make sure it's not just a reaction but
that it's really
a well thought out systematic
investigation
that says that makes you feel okay with
adjusting that mean
yeah i can i a hundred percent agree uh
it's very bad practice to start changing
your means due to
every little uh uh hiccup or whim that
happens in the laboratory
and i'm a true believer in having
justification
strong justification for changing a mean
and i didn't realize that c24 had that
appendix so i'll have to check that out
thanks for sharing
uh dr strzeski or savinski any other
comments on that
i i would add something uh really along
the same lines
which would be make sure that your lab
has a policy
in place in advance really well
defined this is when we do this this is
exactly how we do this
and even better this is who can do this
and have that in place
before you get into that situation and
and i
would also add limiting the number of
individuals that can actually
do the practice actually change a mean
can be very very helpful it you know
there's some traceability there
um making sure it's people that are
intimately involved
in in daily qc operations or people in
leadership roles um
i just really think that that's very
very helpful you don't want this to be
something that's happening
constantly which dr roman had kind of
referred to so
and and i would also take even one step
further back and say
make sure there's no analytical problem
first right so
that's a that's a kind of a step that
some people move past
oh and and move into uh this doesn't
look the same i want to change my mean
make sure there's not an analytical
problem you know nail that down first
remove that variable
that's just some big things i would add
before all the other points i agree with
i i have nothing to add on top of that
they've hit the nail on the head
great totally agree you know there's
another question that came in that's
relevant to this topic so let's take
that and then we're going to move on to
the next
sort of theme area and this is really an
intriguing question
there's this guidance there's there's a
concept that it would be acceptable
to take one-third of your acceptable
performance limits as defined by clia so
the total
allowable error as defined by clia take
one third of that
and use that as your standard deviation
i have not heard of that guidance before
uh and i haven't really had time to sort
of
digest it and think about that concept
but um
sort of my gut reaction is i don't know
makes me kind of nervous uh i i'd rather
base my uh my sds
on things that i can measure uh
and sometimes i think that the the clia
limits for allowable error
are kind of a mystery to me i'm not
really sure where they came from
um so i don't know if they're i have
i have a little bit of a problem with
with that accepting that guidance and
i'd like to hear from the panelists what
you all think
uh yeah i'll i'll start us off um
i'm thinking of some specific examples
off the top of my head i know that the
clia limits for
serum calcium are one milligram per
deciliter
and so that would drop us down to 0.33
for the sd and so a 2sd
span on either side that's still 1.33
milligrams per deciliter
and that's a pretty wide target to be
within
so if you think about two of these on
either side of your mean
that's a pretty wide sd range and i
guess
in a way it might be a good sanity check
to make sure that your limits aren't
too wide but i don't know that i would
say that this is
um there might be some analytes for
which this is great
but i think that um it might be kind of
wide for many
analytes depending on the clear limits
yeah i wonder if it's not just a first
pass or
you know some type of a check to start
off but probably not
the best for day to day yeah yeah
and i'll just add that you know again if
we're focusing on statistical qc which i
think is
the common practice in most clinical
labs
that standard deviation it it's not
pulled out of
thin air it's established based on the
analytical performance of the method
so any time you ex you and then you set
your two standard deviations and we all
know that five percent
of the time a point will fall outside of
two standard deviations away from the
mean
but really it is analytical performance
it's data driven
so if you have a point that's exceeding
those sds
it tells you that analytically there is
a performance
issue now i think the allowable total
error considerations come in
when you start thinking about how you're
going to react to those failures and
maybe we'll cover that later
but you know really that you're not
making up the performance of the assay
and i think there's a lot of power
in making sure that you're catching when
things get out of control
analytically all right thank you all
um so let's move to the next theme area
which is one of everyone's favorite and
that's west guard rules
um and i'm gonna ask dr bauman to kick
us off by answering
this question and it's a it's a
straightforward one
what westguard rules should we use
um should we follow the the the writer
goes on to say that using the one two s
rule is too restrictive which is what
they currently follow
um and they're trying to really identify
what's their best practice what what
what rules should
a laboratory use for their tests so dr
bauman why don't you get us started on
this topic
okay thank you dr ganesh i um
you're lucky because my philosophy in
almost everything i try to do is keep it
simple
and um try to do the best you can with
simplistic
simplistic rules in our laboratory
and this is just one approach and i'm
very interested in what the rest of the
panel does
we really use two westgard rules
we use what's called a 1 2s repeat and
i'll explain that because it's not the
traditional 1 2s
and then we use a one oh actually we use
a one
3.5 s and i can get into why it's 3.5
s um but those are the two rules we use
the reason for that so his traditionally
a 1 2s would be considered a warning
rule because we know that one in 20
times
qc will fall greater than two standard
deviations away from the mean
um so that that will happen often and
and it's really a warning and if you
look at
traditional westgard rules they would
say to treat that as a warning and
continue
testing and then if the next time you
measured qc
or if qc across concentrations without
one to sd
again now that's real and the
fundamental problem that i have with
that
is that what that means is that my one
two
s that i measured maybe four hours maybe
eight hours maybe 24 hours ago
that was real and i didn't catch it so
now
i'm thinking always of patient impact
now i have
24 hours of patients at risk so what we
do in our laboratory
is a 1 2s repeat when the text see a 1
2s failure they immediately repeat the
qc
and if it's if it's then out again it's
considered a 2 2s
and that is a qc failure and we take
corrective action
so what that um it if it comes back in
it means that that one 2s was a false
alarm as we expect and that happens
often as
it should if your sds are set
appropriately
and but we feel that we're
catching systemic shifts much sooner
than just using the traditional 1 2s
warning
and waiting for that next qc measurement
event
so in addition so
our experience is that it works very
well we do ongoing assessment to see how
many
errors we have but dr kurt parvin
also published a paper it's been several
years ago now
where he you know he was talking to all
of us
colleagues laboratorians and he's a
biostatistician who focuses on qc
and he said you know i see labs that are
doing this they're doing this 1 2s
repeat
let's see really what it does and he
simulated power function graphs
comparing a 1
2s rule a 1 2s repeat rule and a 1
3s rule and that one 2s repeat
actually has the error detection power
of using a 1 2s warning which would have
tons of false alarms but high error
detection
and it has the false rejection rate of
approximating a 1 3s rule which we know
has very low false alarms but
um but not very good error detection
so i can tell you in our laboratory it's
a 1 2s repeat and
a 1 3.5 s to catch
the sporadic random errors that's why we
have it set at 1.313.5s
knowing that a 22s will catch most
things
so that's our approach simple we think
it works
was it that's fascinating thank you for
sharing your practice
was it was it it you know it seems
simple to
implement um but what was it like
getting the laboratory technologists to
buy into that strategy
oh easy because they're not getting a
lot of false alarms now
that they don't know what to do with
they don't have alert fatigue
um there aren't all of these you know
10x
rules that are firing when it's just
because your means a little bit off but
yet we've said we're not adjusting our
means
so it actually was very easy to
implement
and to get buy in and when you explain
it
as i hope i just did you know it's it's
data driven and it's evidence-based
so that makes it easier to accept as
well that's one
yeah uh dr schracevsky what do you guys
do
what's your what's your approach to um
west guard rules
i i really the only thing i would add
here is that it's really
dependent upon the system and and what
you're testing in the analyte and
you know we do things differently in our
automated labs than we do in our manual
labs and
that's a huge part of it if you're
talking about some huge automated area
versus
manual eliza's or something like that so
i
i really i guess the only thing i would
add here is to caution
people to think about the analyte and to
p
and people to think about the type of uh
method that's being used because you
might want to adjust accordingly
otherwise we all know about the issues
of 1
2s triggers and the alert fatigue and
everything that goes along with that so
um more rules are not necessarily better
i think that you know
dr bauman's approach of keeping it
simple is
critical uh and so when it's appropriate
i think it works out best
to keep it relatively simple yeah dr
stravinsky
no i agree and you know the thing is
that i like to think about is the effect
that it has
on your daily maintenance and coming
back up from your maintenance
if you think about some of the large
animated lines we're now using in a lot
of laboratories
it's a three-hour process to get your
instrument taken down
at daily maintenance qc and back up
and it's important to detect errors of
course
but exactly what both uh dr bauman and
dr strzewski have highlighted
is this issue of alert fatigue and alarm
fatigue
and chasing down um alerts that
aren't really necessarily going to
affect the analytical performance
and of course the whole idea of a
24-hour clock
and our batches not being 100 samples
necessarily
with these high throughput analyzers can
be several thousand samples affected
so i think it's important to catch that
error early yeah
i i i've just do on your um approach dr
bauman i i'm really intrigued by it
um i like the simplicity of it i love
that your technologist bought into it
very quickly um you know we were often
uh
what's often taught to us is that we
know
what's often taught is that if you can't
take a one size one-size-fits-all
approach to everything and i think
that's kind of what dr chrisseski was
was suggesting um but at the same time
having different
qc rule strategies for a bunch of
different analytes on a
on a multi-analyte analyzer it becomes
really complicated even with um with
with computerized systems
uh so you know having that type of stand
you know laboratories are all about
trying to achieve standardization
and i don't see why qc rules should be
any different as long as it's an
effective strategy at detecting errors
and minimizing that alert fatigue that
you refer to
um okay let's see uh let me just look at
quick take a quick look at what's come
in on the questions
um okay here's one that's relevant to
the topic we're
addressing are any of us able to speak
about the six sigma approach to qc
in this discussion and i think what the
person is referring to is sort of
matching sort of west guard rules
against the sigma metric of an
assay so if the sigma metric is low you
do more
you have you apply more qc rules if you
have a high
uh like the six sigma method then you
can get away with say
just a one three s rule
and i think that you know i think we've
already addressed that uh
in our discussion you know dr bauman's
approach of keeping it simple
um uh and and then i think but uh
with at the same time being cognizant
that
there's no single perfect qc strategy
right and laboratories need to do what's
what what what's best for them and for
their analytes and for their analytical
measuring systems and for their workflow
um so lots of ideas abound but i'm just
going to leave
it at that unless any of the panelists
want to chime in about that specific
question
the only thing i would add is i know
that kurt parvin has been mentioned
already once
so i will say that i know that he's done
some excellent work on
looking at the effectively what's what i
would call a risk-based
qc strategy based on the sigma metric um
if i could
recite the the the citation off top of
my head
i'd refer people to to look for that one
i think it
that would be the most efficacious use
of time would be to take a look
at those publications
and i i would add that you could
actually instead of
tying that into just westgard rules you
could also tie the risk
component which of course was tied to
sigma uh to
the the levels of controls so how many
levels people use is a very common
question right do you want to use
two levels or more um so i guess i would
take the opportunity to
talk about that a little bit more um the
uh
idea of two concentrations a minimum of
two concentrations is obviously
recommended um but if you if you did
want to use more stringent rules or if
you were using a sigma value
to kind of guide you and so let's say
you have a low sigma value so high level
of risk
associated or a high high risk for error
then you'd want to use more more levels
of qc you could also
say the same thing about really wide
amrs or wide reference intervals
when you know that you're going to need
you know controls at
the low end versus the high end or if
you've got different performance at the
low end versus the high end
so that really does bring that sigma
value into the
conversation as well right because it
brings the whole risk value
in into the into the conversation and
obviously not all of our analytes that
we measure
carry the same amount of risk right we
care about all of our results but they
just don't all have the same amount of
risk associated with them
so i think that's where the sigma value
can be pretty informative
as well depends how you use it but
all right i just want to acknowledge
that we have lots and lots of questions
coming in which is great thank you for
your interest in your enthusiasm
i think we could go on all day for eight
hours talking about this but we don't
have that much time
but really keep the questions coming
because they are informative and we'll
figure out
we'll figure out we can't address them
all but
we'll figure out something to do with
them in the future um so the next theme
is um right up dr savinsky's alley and
that's about moving averages and the
question essentially becomes
are moving averages more powerful than
controlled than running
um commercial quality control material
and or so it's better yet and then so
let me follow i'm sorry to interrupt
so let's talk about moving averages are
they better
than uh qc are they used in conjunction
with qc and
and maybe mark start us off with
explaining just what they are so that
we're all in the same playing field
sure so the moving averages is
i'm going to address it in a broad sense
and that we're talking about
taking the either a statistical
typically a mean
or we could also talk about medians so
let's say the mean or median patient
value for a particular analyte
so rather than just calculating that
once per day or once per hour
a moving average essentially is just
recalculating
the average or median uh patient value
every time you get a new value included
so you
you basically set a fixed window of the
number of patient samples that are going
to be
put into the function and then you
monitor that
a single value as a uh effectively
almost another way of another qc
so they have the average values will
plot
on a chart that can be set up to look
just like the levy jetting insert
um in regards to which one is more
powerful
if we're going to say the term powerful
then that really implies we're doing a
statistical analysis
of detecting an error with
traditional qc or a patient-based
moving average qc and i don't really
think it's the the right way to
say which one's more powerful which
one's not and part of that is going to
depend on a lot of things
predominantly the number of qc values
you're running per day
the number of levels of qc that you're
running as dr strzozkie has
pointed out um the analyte
so things such as electrolytes in my
experience
including bicarb we can detect shifts
in analytical performance quite readily
with using just a basic moving average
without any data transformation
without any normalization or anything
fancy
we can detect shifts readily and in fact
we do and
it saved us from these horrendous ideas
of having to rerun
thousands of samples because we missed a
a shift with our qc or a shift occurred
between qc events
but i would say that really they work
together
quite well the moving averages in my
mind
supplement or enhance
your error detection between qc events
um what else did i want to say about
that powerful
that you know i lost my train of thought
there oh right other analytes
um things such as that are really skewed
like ast
alt creatinine i
don't even i mean glucose i've not i
mean someone may have gotten it to work
for glucose
but um i don't know about your the qc
not qc the
concentration of glucose that you see in
your laboratories
is quite wide so getting an average
value is
very difficult so i would say targeted
to the right analytes
using the right protocols they can
greatly reduce the number of patient
samples that are affected by an
analytical shift
but in no way are they going to
completely replace
your traditional liquid qc
that you run in your laboratory are
there guidance documents or great
literature that you could point us to
maybe not right this second but we could
get
that information out to the attendees
that help
a laboratory who wants to do this start
down that path
yeah there's a whole list of different
publications that i could refer people
to
um there's actually been a a lot of
publications in the last two years
there is a working group within the ifcc
the international federation for
clinical chemistry
and it's a group that i've been very
fortunate to work with
we have published a number of different
guidance documents
both on how to set up patient-based qc
in your own laboratories
and as well as what we feel the field
needs in order for patient based qc
to become more widely adopted
it is time consuming to set up it
benefits us greatly
and what we're really hoping for is we
can get manufacturers to
help us in terms of having software
tools that can analyze a laboratory's
historical data
um dr dr bauman what's your experience
with using
moving averages and then i'm going to
have the same question for dr suzeski
um so thank you dr grenache
dr cervansky's is certainly the expert
on this
and we we have attempted it in my
laboratory
uh we've put quite a bit of effort into
it we did some simulation studies i'll
say our pilot analytes were
calcium chloride and creatinine we were
just trying
you know three for various reasons we
you know the the intricacies are setting
that
bin size um which dr sivinsky talked
about setting the
the ranges of what's going to trigger a
warning
we worked through all that we even did
some simulation studies where we
we artificially simulated what a 2sd
shift would look like in the patient
population
and then we tried to tweak our bin sizes
to say
how many patients would you need to
detect this
shift so we were really excited about it
and then we went to implementation and
what we did was
every time the moving averages triggered
a warning we immediately ran our qc
to see if the assay was actually out of
control and
i'm so sad but in every single case it
was a false alarm
and in every single case it was patients
being drawn
in our hospital morning rounds so the
one thing i think that hasn't been
mentioned here it's such a sophisticated
tool and i
i do think it has use i i i haven't
given up
in our laboratory but your patient
population is huge
and we even though i should say we're in
a highly i direct a highly
automated core lab we have a lot of
ambulatory outpatients so we thought it
would work
but there's enough really sick people
integrated into that population that we
just couldn't get it to work
so i'm probably going to have to take dr
cervinski out
for a coffee or a beer or something
and have him help us through this
because i do think it's a powerful tool
but i i'll just say we've had challenges
in our hands
i think that's a really important point
dr bauman is the
is the patient mix in your workflow
uh we use moving well we we don't use
moving averages we calculate a mean
every
n of 25 samples and when we see
when an alarm goes off um we one of the
first things the technologists do
is is look at the demographics of those
last 25 and
oftentimes that alarm is due to an
influx of samples that came from
maybe one of our cancer centers
yeah uh dr schracetsky what's your
experience yeah so i would
um add a couple of things to to kind of
tie all of this together actually and
that is uh
dr sivinski mentioned moving averages
and also moving medians so means or
medians and
we use medians so that might kind of tie
in what dr bauman was talking about as
well we do that because of the nature of
the testing
that that we do of course we're a
national reference lab versus a primary
care institution i think that can really
be a a good way to
uh use medians versus means that could
be very useful
um and that's because we're seeing the
extremes right so a medium can be
quite helpful for us i i do also
echo the sentiment that it i would not
put it in a competition
with your traditional liquid qc
materials i think it's a supplement
right
it's it's never going to be the end-all
be-all or you don't want to
excuse me replace all of your qc but
it's really i consider it a supplement
and really it tells us something
different right it's a different
matrix it's our real patients it's our
real patient samples and so if you're
trying to pull apart
some really complicated issue or maybe
you're wondering whether or not there's
something going on with your qc
i'm always interested to see what's
happening with patient sample
so the matrix might be an important
thing you can learn from it
and then the last thing i would add is
that data group size
and there was a paper that was published
several years ago now from the arup
group that
looked at the statistical relevance of
the different sizes of those data
packets
and what that n is and so we depending
on the type of analyte and the
the you know the volume that can be very
helpful as well and i can add that to
the list of publications that might be
useful or provided later
great thank you let's move on to the
next
theme area which is recovering from
errors
and i'm going to ask dr bauman to kick
us off in this
part of the dialogue and dr bauman if
you could just start by
uh by sort of uh addressing the topic
from a
a bird's eye view you know recovering
from errors is a really critical
import a critical thing that
laboratories do
and i my experience is that the practice
varies
widely and again and that's for good
reason right there's no one best way to
do this
i know you've written about this and you
have some deep experience could you just
start us off by explaining what your
sort of philosophy is
yes i'd be happy to uh so i
i think if you look at the field of
laboratory qc we spend
a huge amount of time figuring out what
rules to use
what qc material to use how to set our
means in sds
and when and basically i think from a
bench staff
standpoint uh you just want the qc to be
in
you wanna you want it to be in don't
wreck my day
but the fact is when qc is out
there's more to worry about than just
getting qc
back in and i think we have to remember
that qc
is our surrogate for telling us that the
patient results we're reporting are
accurate and that's
why we do that's why we invest all of
this time into setting up
our qc strategies and our materials and
our means
so when that qc is out we need i think
our
our gut reaction shouldn't just be
get the qc back in our gut reaction
should be
what's happening with our patient
results what did we report that was
inaccurate is there harm is there
patient
impact so i think you know 30 000 foot
view
philosophically is to really remember
what qc failures reflect
and they reflect that your patients are
at risk your patient results are at risk
so i think the and i i'll echo
also what dr straszewski said earlier
about having
sops i think that you need to
have it completely laid out how you're
going to react
to the patient impact portion of acute
failure
before it ever happens you don't want to
be doing this on the fly so i call this
the recovery phase
and it really needs to be laid out so i
think the steps i always kind of lay it
out in four steps and they're very
simple steps
um you know first is the qc failure real
and by by real i say just the common
sense things make sure
it wasn't the wrong level of material or
levels were swapped or
something else was going on but that
doesn't mean keep repeating the qc over
and over
because if you've set up your rules
properly you're detecting a
real problem second contain it so make
sure you're not
continuing to report off that analyzer
if you truly have an out of control
condition
it is important enough that you stop
testing hopefully you have a redundant
analyzer
but either way contain it and then of
course you want to fix
you want to fix the assay you want to
recalibrate or
change the reagent pack whatever the
problem was if there's a problem with a
pipe header or a tubing
you want to fix that but hopefully you
have redundancy in your lab that you can
start considering a patient impact as
well
so in our laboratory there are again
numerous approaches to this
but you have your mindset should really
be that
from that out of control condition that
you've just detected
the patient's results that you reported
are at risk of being incorrect
from that point back to whenever your
last
good qc was so you need to
actually repeat those patient samples
repeat test them on an analyzer that is
in control
now if you're a small lab low volumes
and maybe you've only run
20 or 30 patients since the last qc
event
you can re-measure all of them and do
that comparison and see whether you
reported anything erroneously
i come from a very high volume high
throughput automated lab
we go back in batches of 10 patients
that's not a magic number by any means
it's a number that
is practical and it works for us
but then what do you do so you're now
repeating patient
samples of results that in our lab we
report in real time there's auto
verification
so these results have already been
reported and that's why i think
recovery processes need to be set out
beforehand because it has to be
immediate you don't want to catch this
the next day
and say oh my gosh all of the tshs that
we reported yesterday
are at risk so it's immediate
and but we what we also have our
criteria
set for what constitutes needing to
revise a result
because if if you reported a tsh i'll
use tsh as an example a tsh of
five and when you repeat it it's
4.8 that's really
within the imprecision of the assay so
what we also have
in we in our lab we call it our revision
limits
but these are what kind of differences
constitute
needing to correct a result so we will
go back in batches of 10
we will compare the original reported
result with the result that we're now
repeating
on an in-control analyzer and we compare
those results and if it
exceeds our pre-established criteria we
will correct that result
so that's our that's my very simplistic
you know four-step approach
i think um a few of the caveats
are you know if you're dealing with
analytes where
normal is undetectable and your last 10
results were undetectable
keep going back until you have
measurable values so there needs to be
some common sense
incorporated if you have analytes that
are
intrinsically unstable and can't be
repeated that also needs to be built
into
your recovery plan
so that's how we approach it um
and i i'm happy to elaborate but i also
want to give others a chance to chime in
yeah excellent um uh you know i i want
to
empha i want to emphasize that the need
for that sop
on um what steps you take after
this type of discovery um i'll i'll
confess that we recent here at tri-core
we recently had a large-scale testing
error that qc
would not have detected because it
wasn't it was a manual
it was the instruments were fine it was
just how
some manual programming of the analyzer
was occurring when when our track was
being replaced
and um when it happened and we
recognized that we didn't have
an sop to follow and i was doing exactly
what you just said not to do dr bauman
was
trying to fix this on the fly uh it
it was very difficult and it took longer
than it should have
so uh we're now working with our quality
and safety teams to create an sop that
will help guide us because it is a lot
to do
when you have to go back you know if
you're if you're trying to change one or
two results it's fairly easy um
but when you've got a lot it becomes uh
much more complicated
um and before we go into the next topic
there was a question that came in that's
that's relevant and and dr bauman you
already addressed it a little bit
but it's essentially um what do you what
what's the best practice
when you might have a a qc failure
but the um the the error is still within
what what many would be the total
allowable error
um you know do you have to correct those
patient results and
you already touched on that because you
guys have developed revision limits for
your various tests and if the repeat
result is within that limit
there's no correction needed can you
just touch base on how you
develop those revision limits
yes and um it is something
it's a lot of effort to go through your
whole test menu and establish those
but it's so worth it when things go
wrong so we do
we actually use allowable total error
we do look at um clia
recommended differences as well we kind
of compile
all of the sources of evidence that
there are for these things
and then we we look at the imprecision
of the assay
i would say the main driver we use is
allowable total error i've been
toying with the idea of using reference
change values
as that amount of significant change
that may be a
nice tool to use as well
but mostly allowable total error and
you're right in so an assay like ast
where the imprecision is excellent we're
at
cvs of you know one to two percent
and yet the allowable total error is
more in the
15 to 20 percent when we have a qc
failure we hardly ever revise patient
results and that's
okay that's what we want we then have
analytes like calcium
which is notoriously imprecise
for how it's used clinically and when we
have
a 22s failure for calcium
we often are revising several results so
it will depend um we've we have some
strategies in the lab where we're trying
to
to optimize this but we're
very limited time if anyone's interested
they can reach out to me i can explain
more but
in general that's how we do it
great thank you um before i go on to the
next theme just uh
dr savinthia straszewski anything else
to add to the
recovery okay all right let's move on
um let's talk about qualitative qc you
know much of what we're talking about
has been very focused on quantitative qc
qualitative qc is certainly important
and it's out there
um and so i'm going to ask um i guess dr
savinsky you want to get us started
what's the best practice to evaluate
qualitative qc
uh do you just look at the qualitative
result
or do you uh many times you get a
numeric result
that the qualitative interpretation is
based on so what do you all do
yeah so not only best practice depending
on your accrediting agency you may have
to
track that and treat it as you would a
regular quantitative qc so we do monitor
the instrument signal single to noise
cut
off signal to calibrate or cut off
whatever assay term you use
as we would monitor any quantitative qc
and i think that the natural idea and
the reason behind that
is that when you have a qualitative
assay that is going to be positive or
negative
at a certain threshold and your
qc is right above that threshold if it
were to go negative
okay but let's suppose you have a
threshold of one
and anything above one is considered
positive and your qc is running at a
hundred with an sd of two
you know if you're not monitoring that
shift
and your 100 suddenly becomes 50.
you have to wonder what's happening to
those patients that are right around two
are they now below one um conversely if
a patient go from negative to positive
so you have to really assess your
your qc in a quantitative manner even
though you're reporting qualitatively
because you could miss significant
decrements or
changes in your instrument performance
if you're not monitoring that signal
if we're talking about other devices
that are visually read
i don't think that really applies here
but
it is a regulatory standard and even if
it weren't
i would say you should be monitoring
that signal to make sure that you're
not getting false positives or false
negatives
dr straszewski or dr bauman do you have
anything to add
i i i would say that really determining
where you're putting those qc
are the critical part which is you know
what what dr sevinsky's mentioning here
above and below that cutoff that's the
main thing that i would worry about
and also completely agree that this is
usually dictated
to us as to what we need to do so
what if you have qc material for a
qualitative essay right but the qc
material gives you a really
high signal value and a really low
signal value
and we're trying to look at performance
really that's at that decision threshold
that cut point
um some advocate for diluting your qc
material to reach that target
what do you all do or would you would
recommend
i i personally wouldn't because you're
starting to affect the matrix of that qc
and then you have to wonder about
stability how accurately it actually is
it a linear dilution
um what i've done in the past and what
we've
tried to do as much as we possibly can
is we look for different material near
the cutoff
at times that has been a challenge
because either materials are too high or
too low
but we've also gotten materials right
near the cut-off
and sometimes a non-statistical shift
could make a sample go from positive to
negative
for the qc material so it really is a
balancing act
and i wish we were successful 100 of the
time
in finding the perfect material but i
we're not
we do our best doctor obama do you have
any experience in this space and any
advice
um limited experience we don't do a lot
of qualitative assays but i would agree
with the other
experts on the panel wholeheartedly
yeah i would add you can you can pool
samples in order to make your own
controls
as well we end up having to do that
quite a bit so that we've got qc
values where we want them to but i fully
recognize not all labs can do that
very efficiently so i i understand that
but that is another possibility
yeah in our in our special chemistry and
immunology lab we have to do the same
we we do we use pool patient samples
yeah i i'm i like using authentic
patient samples
in some cases for qc it's just it's it's
labor-intensive and difficult to manage
that's
that's the challenge for us and i doubt
we're unique
um so we are coming up on the hour and
uh this has been a really
fun chat um i don't know about you guys
but you know
we have just you know lots and lots of
questions that we did not get to so
um maybe if bio-rad is uh supportive and
you guys are enthusiastic about it we
could do round two in the nearest
the near-ish future um and address some
of these questions that are really
really important and um uh worth
consideration and
maybe we can get together as a group and
do that again as a later date
um so i'm going to turn it back to susie
and i'm going well first i want to thank
you guys the panelists and my friends
and colleagues for this conversation
we've had this morning
uh re i i i certainly learned uh some
things and i'm gonna be
uh really stewing about what dr bauman
does regarding her qc rules
um and i want to thank the audience for
taking the time to listen to
the four of us chat with each other so
susie you want to
wrap things up i would love to
and i want to thank all of you for this
great discussion and before we go
i want to thank the audience as well for
joining us today and for their
interesting
questions and questions we did not have
time for today
will be addressed and posted in the
event resources
this webcast will be available on demand
in the auditorium
if you found this informative and
helpful please share it with your
colleagues
for the next webinar on may 19th we will
have dr
james nichols from vanderbilt university
school
of medicine presenting on practical tips
to manage
laboratory qc data and please stay tuned
and watch your email inbox for the
invitation
and don't forget to visit the new
product lab in the virtual event
where you can find information about our
featured quality control
products until next time everyone thank
you all
and have a great day bye bye everyone
thank you